when looking at the Los Angeles
restaurants I'm a little bit of a foodie
I notice none of the very popular
restaurants are on there how do you deal
with that problem that a Nobu or you
know whatever famous restaurants just
not going to go for this does that mean
you're always gonna be you know you talk
about being the high-end of the group on
sites obviously as Groupon but can you
crack into those because I would like to
see some discount at one of those places
is it just not possible to sell them on
that I'm writing it down
just getting a reservation is one thing
you know right so that if a business
doesn't need customers then they don't
need us there's nothing we can do that's
what we do but beyond that I mean
there's thirteen spirit award-winning
restaurants that have worked us all over
the country there's like world-renowned
art museums like the Art Institute of
Chicago we sold 5000 memberships and in
a and this was like your which increased
the membership based Athena thing
building over the last hundred years by
six percent only single day so sorry ins
what worries you about the business
today is there is there something that's
your massive concern that keeps you up
at night there's no I mean a lot of
things but but nothing stands out I
think you know what I think about is how
do we not become how do we not start to
suck and I want to make sure that all
those things that like EDM just name a
game that made them start to suck don't
have mass and that's and that's what
what are the things that made those
companies suck was it the lack of
innovation was it too much red tape
what do you wouldn't what do you think
what do you think that's a good question
I'm not sure but I think that's the
musician in them coming out because as a
former musician myself like you look at
bands that get popular and you know
they're never gonna stay that way
forever because somehow they're gonna
just start sucking cuz every band does
at some point
yeah I wrote some email the other day
and I thought this is like late 80s
David Bowie email you know getting bad
it could be like a theme song for a
really bad 80s movie
so I guess innovation would be it
how do you stay innovative as a company
when you get so big that so much of your
time must be spent on just hiring and
managing all these people how many
employees are there and how do you keep
the innovation going we have about 300
employees you're having about 40 a month
we just we try to make time for it you
try to just hire it so you have enough
flex to be able to innovate I think just
naturally the people here it's
innovation is built into the culture a
core part of the culture is the
editorial team which is which is just
very very creative and I think it's a
great system so I'm not worried about
innovation as much as I am think about
making sure people know each other and
people feel like their people feel like
they have the same sense of ownership
and autonomy and ability to make a real
difference on in the future of the
company that there's 20 people did you
know a year ago when Wendy